So have a festival, what do I want to do with it?
>> Well, think about it. What are, what are the things in
a festival that you care about most? What do you want to track?
>> I want to know, I mean, I want to
know when the festival is. I want to know, I
want to know a lot of things. What it is,
who's going, who, I mean, who's playing, tickets, everything.
>> Great. Well, what we did now was created our festival object. And
so, that's going to be the overall thing that we store our data into.
>> Okay.
>> But then on that object, you can create fields,
which are the characteristics about that object that we want to
track. So, the object being festival, those characteristics you named were.
>> Like start date, and date, that kind of thing?
>> Exactly.
>> Okay.
>> So, in order to create those we can do that
by going to this little tab on the right hand side.
>> This little arrow guy?
>> Yeah. It's our quick access menu to toggle between the
app, and the administrative set up. So, let's add some fields.